pas et on avait raison dire que quand on
a commencé cette campagne quelques mois
on était vraiment les challenger et
j'avais des gens pour me dire tu seras
jamais réélu aujourd'hui on fait presque
jeu égal avec le ps on s'envoie d'un
côté six ans de l'autre donc ces
dernières semaines on a dit mais le
deuxième poste est accessible et c'était
le cas on ne nie pas arrivé mais très
honnêtement réussir à rééquilibrer la
gauche ainsi avec un pilier
effectivement toujours autour du parti
socialiste et un autre pilier finalement
autour des écologistes et des divers
gauche
je crois que c'est un signal est un
message très important et on est très
très heureux ce soir
vous êtes un des rescapés cologie si je
puis dire puisque vous c'est vous
siégiez au groupe écologiste au sénat
lors de votre premier mandat
où allez-vous ségéla en l'occurrence ben
ali côté là on est en train de regarder
les résultats qui arrivent il y a au
moins 4,5 écologistes il y a des divers
gauche qui ne se retrouve pas dans les
autres offres l'objectif demain moi je
me remontent évidemment sur parité
demain matin c'est maintenant de
reconstruire un groupe écologie je pense
que pour le débat au sénat
avoir une voix écologistes et divers
gauche c'est important je crois que
c'est faisable et donc c'est déjà un peu
un appel à ceux qui finalement
souhaiterait aussi que cette expression
là soient présentes il y aura un groupe
communisme non c'est certain je crois
qu'il faut un groupe écologiste
je crois qu'on est tous avec des
collègues disponible pour regarder avec
kiel le construire c'est l'objectif
maintenant